to be very frank with you vaynernation I
don't give a [ __ ] if Tyler or you think
today was rough because I had 17
meetings that he couldn't be a part of
because I'm actually running a [ __ ]
business here I'm not from some [ __ ]
teenage beanie Bopper trying to do a
vlog or some [ __ ] influencer doing a
[ __ ] blog or some [ __ ] family
that's open for some free detergent
because of their [ __ ] blog I'm
[ __ ] working here Tyler so sorry that
your [ __ ] video blog is rough
[Music]
but let me tell you what's not rough
what's not rough is we're living through
the great era of ground shift in
marketing and business
everybody in this [ __ ] amazing town
of New York City which is let me just
tell you everybody who's not here
[ __ ] vibrant at Tenet p.m. right now
cuz 98 percent of your cities are
[ __ ] sleeping
everybody here is [ __ ] their [ __ ]
collective pants because the ground is
shifting everything that our
grandparents and parents grew up with
everything that we knew tried-and-true
the stable pillars of media commerce
influence persuasion the way we make
decisions the things we buy and how what
is cool and what is not is unfuckin halt
the world is on call and you know what
that means
hustlers the opportunity is obnoxious so
whether you're focusing on vlogs or
influencers or how to have Instagram
stories or how to create alexa voice
skills or how to create your own podcast
because you see i'm [ __ ] full
committed tilt if you are not following
my podcast [ __ ] pissed
the way I call today the the sum up of
all my meetings say none of which and
just watched is that the earth is moving
there's instabilities in the foundation
of how it was which makes an innovator
like me really [ __ ] happy
and what suffocates all UB players
because you like it you like it nice
slow and stable let it be very clear
with this ending rant that game is over
and the people that are gonna win over
the next five to seven years are gonna
be very comfortable in controlled
[ __ ] chaos so you better get your
speed up you better work harder you
better work smarter you better try
things you better keep your
subjectiveness and your ego at the door
because that slows you down and it
doesn't make you do you better [ __ ]
move
[Music]